hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
today we're doing the q a video for idea
number 22
which was cosmology and miraculously
somehow this week nothing went terribly
wrong
previous week i had broken the blog i
didn't break the blog
actually wordpress keeps updating itself
so it made it impossible to leave
comments
uh those have all been restored the blog
is working out we got good comments i
think you know the microphones and
lighting and everything
are good in case you don't know i wrote
a blog post
um on how i make these videos so if
you're
regular watchers viewers you remember
that in the q
a video i think number three which is on
force energy in action
at the end i did a little video tutorial
about how i was making these videos
but uh number one i've gotten better at
it and my techniques and and programs
have changed a little bit
and number two it's actually ironically
easier to learn
what i do from a text blog post than
from a video
because i can say you know i'm using
screenflow and you can click
and then go to what that is so check out
the blog preposterous universe.com
blog if you want to know more about the
behind the scenes picture
of what's going on here or make the
biggest ideas videos otherwise
uh it's pretty straightforward we got
good questions so let's get to them
um one question which is not a question
it was a uh
enduratum i made a boo boo and i was
talking about henrietta levitt who
showed the period luminosity relation uh
for cepheid variable stars i went on and
on about parallax
but levitt was not directly using
parallax after all i just sort of
jumbled that into my memories of the
history of astronomy
um what in fact she just did was look at
cepheid variables that are in either the
large or small magellanic clouds
these are small satellite galaxies which
people more or less
had an idea that that was true and she
sort of uh
assumed for good reasons and correctly
that
if you have a bunch of cephe variables
that are in one little sub galaxy then
for
all intents and purposes you can treat
them as the same distance away so even
if you don't know how far away they are
you know that they're basically the same
size so there's a relationship between
their apparent luminosity and their
actual
uh distance so that was sorry thank you
for the i forget who said it but thank
you for the correction
there um in terms of actual questions
you know let me i think a lot of them
are pretty
i was happy to see a lot of them are
pretty straightforward
expansion of the universe kind of
questions how we talk about the
expansion of the universe how we derive
it uh the predictions for it
and so it's good because we
live in our everyday lives in you know
rooms
and spaces that are not expanding so
understanding what it means to say the
universe is expanding can be a little
bit tricky
so one question is uh the big bang
which actually let me let me just talk
about the big bang because i didn't uh
say as much as i could about it it was a
pretty long video that we did
so we have this thing where over time
you have the scale factor remember the
scale factor as a function of time tells
you the relative distances between
things
and putting aside speculative ideas like
inflation and so forth
the basic curve looks like this okay i'm
not going to set
t equals 0 at the beginning because who
knows when the beginning was but it's
expanding and in the future
we start accelerating so it looks like
that but okay
we're accelerating now we've recently
started to accelerate so the point is
there is a moment when
a equals zero when the scale factor was
zero okay and
this is a prediction of classical
general relativity right
einstein in 1915-16 came up with this
theory of gravity you can check out
previous biggest ideas videos
to see what i'm talking about general
theory of relativity and as we said you
plug in this idea of a homogeneous and
isotropic universe a smooth
universe that is uniform on large scales
into the equations of general relativity
you get some predictions
and if the universe is made of ordinary
stuff
right matter and radiation okay so i
said we're forgetting about inflation
and stuff like that
then there's a very strong prediction
that at some point in the past
the scale factor was zero a equals zero
that's the big bang and it's a
singularity
much like the singularity at the center
of black holes
okay shouldn't say the center remember
we talked about in the in the gravity
video
uh the singularity inside black holes is
in the future
once you're there the big bang
singularity is in the past
so it is very similar but also different
in that that that one fact is a very
crucial difference if people ever ask
you you know
could the universe be a black hole it's
like the opposite of a black hole it's
like a white hole there's a singularity
in our past
with the big bang not in our future okay
and
um stephen hawking actually his first
major
contribution to science was showing that
it doesn't matter that we made all these
approximations about the universe being
perfectly smooth
there is still going to be a singularity
in the past
in classical general relativity if the
universe is made of ordinary stuff
and what he did actually it was roger
penrose who
did you know the foundational work doing
uh what are now called
singularity theorems for black holes
showing that if you crunch into the
black hole you will hit a singularity in
the future
hawking basically ran the clock
backwards and showed that the same thing
is true
for cosmology and the singularity is a
place where
the riemann curvature tensor or other
ways of measuring the curvature of the
universe
blow up become infinitely big the
curvature of space-time itself
is infinite okay so what do we make of
that what we make of that
is as people have long said general
relativity is not correct
it is not correct at the big bang
basically the
prediction of general relativity is that
general relativity itself breaks down
and this is incredibly non-surprising
from the point of view of anyone who
cares about the real world rather than
the particular theory if you care about
general relativity
then you're a little bit upset by this
but if you care about the real world you
know the general relativity is not the
final answer we have quantum mechanics
and general relativity is a classical
theory
so when general relativity is breaking
down near a singularity what it's
telling you is
the approximation that we can treat
everything classically and just do
classical general relativity is no
longer a good approximation
so we should do quantum gravity or
something like that we don't have the
right theory of quantum gravity to plug
in so we don't know what to do
so when people say you know many of my
fellow cosmologists like to say things
like
the big bang is you know a moment before
which there are no other moments
it is the beginning of the universe it
didn't pop into existence from any
pre-existing nothingness it is just the
first moment asking what is before the
big bang
is like asking what is north of the
north pole okay
all that might be true but we
don't know it might be false also
because
we don't have a theory that number one
we trust and number two is applicable to
that moment
all we can say for confidence is that
unless there's some exotic form
of matter that gets you out of this like
some repulsive
manner that is important in the early
universe all we can say for confidence
is that general relativity doesn't say
what happens general relativity predicts
a singularity but general relativity is
wrong
so don't trust that okay so maybe the
big bang is the beginning
maybe it's not that's one thing i wanted
to say about the big bang
but the other thing is okay let's
take that under consideration when we
care about you know what the real world
is doing
but still let's figure out what general
relativity is saying
in these circumstances so that we have a
picture in our minds of what some of the
possible things are that could be going
on
so remember we said that for space
it could be positively curved negatively
curved or flat
so space could be
positively curved like a sphere flat
like a table top or negatively curved
like a saddle or a pringle
plus curvature zero curvature
negative curvature and if
it's flat or negatively curved
space could go on forever in any one of
these three
cases space could be finite and compact
in the positively curved case space has
to be compact
one good question that was asked was how
do we know that space has to be compact
if it's positively curved
so parenthetically you know i'm trying
to fill in all the details here that we
glossed over last time
it's very hard or if not impossible to
know something like that because what we
know
is that the size of the universe we know
even this we don't know 100
but to pretty good confidence we know
that the physical size of the universe
is
larger than the size of the observable
universe okay
so when we say the universe is compact
under this theory
we're really extending the theory that
we have beyond what we observed so it
might not be true
but if space is truly uniform and
spherically
uh positively curved then we know it is
indeed
compact and that's not just because
we draw this picture or we embed a
sphere
in three-dimensional space in our minds
and look at it and say it's compact
there are theorems in mathematics which
say if you have
a spatial geometry that has a certain
curvature and that curvature is uniform
what are the possible topologies that
that space
can have and so when i say if it's flat
or negatively curved it can go on
forever or it could be compact
whereas if it's positively curved it
needs to be compact that is a theorem
of uh differential topology and uh we
can actually sort of get a
intuitive feeling for why that's true
because remember
you're not supposed to think about any
of these as embedded in a bigger space
you're supposed to think about living in
them and when we say
positively curved flat or negatively
curved think about two light rays that
initially start off parallel and ask
what happens to them
in a flat geometry they stay parallel
forever negatively curve they go away
positive curve they come together okay
so the point is if you send out a bunch
of test particles
that are moving parallel to each other
or even a little bit away from each
other
in a positively curved geometry if you
just if you don't let it expand if you
just like
keep it fixed in size they will
eventually come back
right they will eventually hit each
other that's not a proof
but that is an intuitive demonstration
of how we do
think about the fact that positively
curved uh
manifolds have to close in on each other
and be compact okay what i wanted to do
was
um that was a footnote what i wanted to
do was talk about
a couple of things the difference
between what i really want to talk about
is
can the universe be infinitely big at
the big bang okay so let's just talk
about that i can we can come back to
where we wanted to go
um so look this is saying if
you just take at face value everything
that is literally
on this uh tablet right now okay on the
one hand
space can be infinite if it's flat or
negatively curved
on the other hand the scale factor will
hit zero
at the big bang so people will say
that the universe was small near the big
bang but
here you're telling me that space is
infinitely big and space being
infinitely big
doesn't change as a qualitative fact
even if the
scale factor is smaller right if space
is infinitely big
and you shrink it by half it's still
infinitely big
so one thing to emphasize is that you
know you have to keep in mind
what when people are talking about the
observable part of the universe
and when they're talking about the whole
universe extended beyond what we can
observe so
when people say you know resolutely and
with confidence that the universe was
smaller near the big bang
that's okay they're not lying but what
they mean is our observable
part of the universe okay so remember we
talked about co-moving volumes if you
take all the matter and radiation
universe today
and just follow its evolution into the
past it forms a volume and you can ask
how big that was in the past
the answer was it was very small like
smaller than a centimeter right our
whole observable universe today
so outside our universe
was the universe small near the big bang
outside our observable universe
uh no not necessarily and that's that's
the important
point so the in the big bang theory
right in the big bang theory not the tv
show but the cosmological model
um what you can have
if if curvature
equals zero so a spatially flat
cosmology
what you're saying is that space time
looks like this here's time
here's space and there is an earliest
moment okay there's an earliest moment
of time
t equals zero by the way let me
emphasize let me go back
to this discussion of uh the universe
popping into existence because
i was trying to say we don't know
whether the big bang was the earliest
moment of time
but it could have been right that's a
that's a possible thing so the other
thing i want to say was
there's a vocabulary problem when the
universe has an earliest moment in time
because of course
none of us are familiar with that as a
feature of the physical world we all
came into existence when time already
existed and will go out when time is
still
existing so we not we don't have the
vocabulary to talk
in ordinary plain spoken language about
the big bang
we are tempted to say that the big bang
came from nothing
right but that's misleading that's wrong
i would go so far as to say it's just
wrong because it makes it sound
like there's something called nothing
that
transformed into the big bang okay but
that's not the idea the idea which again
they may not be true
but the idea is that existence itself
has a boundary at the big bang so that's
why a careful cosmologist will say the
big bang represents the
earliest moment of time the moment of
time
before which there were no other moments
and remember it's a moment of time
it's not a point in space everything is
uniform there's no location at which the
big bang happened it's a moment
and it didn't come from anything there
wasn't anything
before the big bang there was not space
or time or existence or anything like
that
it's just saying that the universe has a
boundary in time it has an earliest
moment
so the coming from nothing vocabulary
is seductive and people use it
but it's not what is being described at
least according to classical general
relativity
now in quantum gravity maybe things are
different it's very plausible that there
is a meaningfulness you could attach
to that phrase but we don't know what it
is exactly right because we don't
understand quantum gravity well
all right there you go um here we're
doing classical general relativity
and saying look space can
i don't know how to draw this how do you
draw an infinitely big space the point
is
that there is space at some early time
it expands and what we mean by expanding
is the scale factor gets bigger but the
scale factor is just the
relative size of the universe at any one
moment of time
so if the universe is infinite infinite
in all directions as freeman dyson
said then it always was in
the big bang model okay it's not
true this is a very long-winded way of
getting to this point
if according if we live in an open
universe a universe that is spatially
infinite in extent
then according to the big bang model
there was never a moment of time in
which the universe was small
things were closer together things were
the scale factor was small the scale
factor went all the way to zero
the density goes to infinity the
curvature goes to infinity
but the universe was always infinitely
big
and this is why to bring it back home it
sort of is not smart
to use a vocabulary of in the big bang
theory the universe
came into existence because you need to
posit an infinitely big universe
coming into existence okay now if you're
really technical you could say wait a
minute
i shouldn't even be defining the size of
the universe
at the big bang because it's curved and
the curvature is infinite and therefore
the metric tensor which we talked about
long ago
doesn't make sense that's perfectly
valid if you want to say that at the big
bang itself
i shouldn't be talking about sizes or
anything like that that's fine i will
totally let you get away with that
but if you give me any instant of time
after the big bang
planck time you know one quadrillionth
of a plank time whatever it is
in classical general relativity the
universe is infinitely big right away
and if you don't like that well then you
just don't like general relativity right
okay it's probably if you don't like it
because you're thinking that the
universe should pop into existence
somehow
but that's not what it is the universe
has a beginning it has a first moment
that's what's going on that's what i
wanted to say okay
um good then there's a sort of slightly
related thing
when we talked about inflation
i drew a picture that looked kind of
like this so there was the
[Music]
expansion of the universe there's t
there's the scale factor
and then i said you know here's the
traditional thing it goes like this
big bang then inflation it would go like
this
quasi-exponential expansion so someone
says wait a minute
it looks from this picture like
during inflation the yellow thing the
universe was expanding
more slowly than it was without
inflation right like the slope here
is less than the slope there but i
thought
that during inflation the universe
expanded super super fast so how
how is this compatible that's a very
good question and there's a there's a
few things
going on here that are worth emphasizing
so
remember the friedman equation the
friedman equation
is uh alexander friedman's invention
soviet physicist who said you can take
this idea of and expand the universe
plug it into einstein's equations get an
equation for it
it says that h squared equals eight
pi g over three rho
and i'm going to add a piece to this i
didn't tell you about last time because
last time i talked about
just if the universe is flat let's add a
little piece just so you know what it
is uh oops it's i got to get it right
otherwise i want to lose my cosmologist
license
k over a squared where k
equals curvature of space
so k is a number plus positive negative
or zero depending on whether space is
flat
zero or uh is possibly curved flat or
negatively curved so
k equals zero the universe is flat
that's why we could ignore it that's
perfectly
valid in fact let's ignore it for a
little bit um and then remember what h
is h is 1 over a
d a dt okay so
for one thing h is not the derivative of
a
h of the derivative of a divided by a
okay so even though
in this little picture here it looks
like the the slope
is very small for d a d t at early times
uh the value of a is also small
so during inflation let me make it in
yellow here
h is approximately constant
that's the idea of exponential expansion
right
a goes as e to the ht where h is
approximately constant
so um even though d a d t even though
the slope
is small as you go to negative values of
t
or whatever the hubble constant is not
any less in fact
let's look at this equation let's set k
equals zero okay
um so this is in other words a
o a dot which is d a d t over a
a dot is defined to be d a dt the slope
of a
so you have to remember that it's that
ratio that gives you h
so when k equals zero let's make our
lives easy
then h squared equals eight
pi g over three rho
and rho is the energy density the you
know we're taking to be uniform
everywhere through space
and this is a number greater than zero
like strictly greater than zero it's
never equal to zero without curvature
okay um
curvature or the cosmological constant
are the two things that can make
h be zero on the right hand side of the
friedman equation
but without that if you're just in a
flat universe this is what you get okay
so h squared is never um zero
if k equals zero and and also
lambda equals zero that's the
cosmological constant because
the reason for that is ordinary energy
densities rho
right what is the number of ergs per
cubic centimeter in photons or protons
and neutrons or in dark matter whatever
real energy densities are never less
than zero okay
but the cosmological constant the vacuum
energy can be either positive or
negative so the two ways to get a
negative number on the right hand side
of the friedman equation
are either to have a cosmological
constant be negative or to have
positive spatial curvature if k is
greater than zero
since it comes in with a minus sign you
can get a negative
term on the right hand side so h is
never zero
in these in this simple case which means
that the universe
has to be expanding and
i mean this is obvious i won't even
write it down but h
is always bigger when rho is bigger
right
so in the past um when rho
the energy density in space the density
of stuff was bigger
h was always bigger in fact if you look
really closely you can
convince yourself h monotonically
decreases
so if we plot the hubble constant
versus time or versus the scale factor
clean that up a bit
it never goes up in this kind of
cosmology it can only go down
then the details of how it goes down
depend on what's going on
and in inflation
this is still true we have ordinary
matter and radiation so i'm going to go
into a little bit more detail about
what's going on in inflation
i'm going to draw this pictures that
look exactly the same but mean
completely different things over and
over again so this was the hubble
constant versus time
let me plot the thing that drives
inflation is some scalar field
again we don't know if inflation is true
but we invent
a field called the inflaton which serves
as
the source of energy density in the
early universe we call it phi
cleverly enough actually the vertical
axis here is v of phi
and this is phi so we have some
potential for phi
okay so phi is a scalar field it has
some potential energy
the energy density in phi is
one half times phi dot squared
the time derivative of i i'll be nice to
you if you're not familiar with this
notation
and write it out d phi dt
i love how now you are familiar with
that notation because you learn calculus
in uh the second biggest ideas video
plus vfi
so there's an energy density that the
field has because it's rolling
right it's moving down the potential and
there's an energy density that gets
just from having a potential right
there's some value of the potential
energy
and so rho for the inflaton is the sum
of two terms
but they're both positive right v of phi
is uh the potential energy is positive
and one half
d phi dt squared is manifestly bigger
than or equal to zero
so the energy density during inflation
is uh greater than zero and in fact you
can do a little bit more work to show
that the energy density only ever
decreases
so even during inflation uh the hubble
constant only ever
decreases so inflation is not something
where
you start with a non-expanding universe
and you start it going
right that you could invent a cosmology
like that and people have but that's not
the usual inflationary story
the usual inflationary stories of the
universe for
some reason starts like this in other
words it starts
with an energy density a super duper
high
energy density in this scalar field
which slowly decreases
and if you want to ask why did the
universe start that way with that energy
density well good you should be asking
that question nobody knows
is the answer maybe stephen hawking knew
or thought he knew
um but then the energy density goes down
and what why inflation works
is you can say well if
d phi dt if the rate at which the scalar
field is rolling down the hill
is small then
phi the scalar field itself is
approximately constant
d phi dt squared is approximately zero
v of phi is therefore approximately
constant because it's just a
function of phi and phi isn't changing
therefore
rho is approximately constant
because i don't know what happened there
because rho is the sum of zero this one
is zero
and this one is a constant and then
you get a constant energy density
therefore h
is approximately constant because
h is proportional to rho here it is
right there
you might say well what if there is
curvature or something like that but
this
curvature term k over a squared
if you start with some constant energy
density in rho
and also k over a squared well as a
increases
k over a squared goes down so even if
you had some k over a squared whether k
was positive or negative doesn't matter
k over a squared is going to diminish
away compared to the constant rho
if you have a row which is approximately
constant and in inflation
you do okay so even though the point of
all this i have these very long-winded
ways of saying very simple things
the point of all this is in inflation
inflation does not ignite the expansion
of the universe from zero to expanding
to beat the band inflation
imagines that the universe always had a
high energy density or at least at some
beginning point which is ill-defined
had a high energy density and the energy
density always ever
decreases during inflation i didn't
prove this to you but if you go through
the equations of motion for the inflaton
field
um this combination of energy uh d phi
dt
squared plus v of phi never increases
in an expanding universe in a
contracting universe it could increase
but as the universe is expanding the
energy density of the inflaton always
goes down
therefore h always goes down even during
inflation
and therefore uh you know the
the last thing to say is if you plug in
rho equals constant h equals constant h
equals a dot over a
we actually inferred this uh last time
where we mentioned it
if h is approximately constant then a is
proportional to e to the ht and you get
this exponential
expansion okay so just trying to clear
up some misconceptions here
inflation is not the beginning of the
expansion of the universe
and we don't really know what happened
at the beginning of inflation
or what put the inflaton up there on his
potential
um should i yeah so that i have more to
say about that should i say it now is
the question why don't i say it now
um why do we talk about inflation at all
wow i'm getting very far away from my
outline but that's okay we're all
friends by now we've spent hours
of our lives together uh you'll put up
with me so
the thing about inflation is it was
invented to it to explain
two puzzles that uh well three puzzles
in fact that alan guth identified all of
them had been identified by other people
before but guth uh actually proposed a
solution to them
for the first time so he he popularized
them
the history of inflation is very
interesting there were other people who
had similar ideas other than goods but
they didn't quite pinpoint the
usefulness of them or the mechanism
to make them happen in a convincing way
so his paper was really the one that got
everyone paying attention to the idea
and the puzzles that were being solved
hadn't really been bothering people that
much it was one of those things where
ah you could see what these puzzles are
and go on your way because they were not
you know in some sense they were not
like direct conflicts between
theory and experiment or theory and
observation right
they were sort of fine-tuning
naturalness problems and these days
decades later uh that's all we have so
we take those very very seriously but
you know in the 1970s and 80s guth
publishes paper in 80
81 i think um there we had like real
experimental puzzles to deal with so
these fine-tuning puzzles were not as
as taken seriously until he proposed the
answer to them
in which case it was so beautiful and
elegant that people suddenly said oh yes
these are very very serious problems
anyway the puzzles of conventional
inflationary cosmology
one was the monopole problem
the monopole problem was a very
straightforward thing we talked earlier
about um topological defects remember we
had a whole video on topology and
geometry
i say this knowing that not all of you
watch the video because i see
the viewership statistics but you should
watch that one and what you find is that
uh
depending on how gauge theories get
broken
we also talked about this in the gauge
theory video so we talked about things
in the topology video which we then put
to use in the gauge theory video
where we said look there could be
symmetry breaking and the symmetry
breaking can lead to topological defects
in ordinary physics as we know it
electric charges come in either pluses
or minuses
so they're up there's there's two
different electric charges they're
completely independent of each other
but in magnetism every magnet has both a
north pole and a south pole
so every magnet in the real world that
we know about in the world of experiment
is bipolar in some sense dipolar yeah
dipolar i guess would be a technical
term
bipolar means something else but then
you can hypothesize could there be a
magnetic monopole could there be just a
north pole if you take an ordinary
magnet which is a north pole and a south
pole
so ordinarily here's a magnet north pole
south pole
you break it in two so you do that well
then this becomes a south pole and that
becomes a north pole
and so you don't actually get let me do
that prettier sorry
a little quick there um if you break it
into two pieces the north pole and the
south pole stay where they were but this
end becomes a south pole of its own this
end becomes a north pole and there's
sort of magnetic field lines stretching
between them
so you never get in ordinary everyday
physics
a magnetic field a magnetic monopole
which is just north or just
south so nevertheless there are theories
like grand unified theories that predict
that there should be
magnetic monopoles because of the
symmetry breaking pattern and the
topology of the gauge fields
and a bunch of people including my
caltech colleague john prescott
and his youth uh noticed that not only
you know we talked about in the
cosmology video and the one this is q a
for
we talked about relics that are created
out of thermal equilibrium
okay like axion particles or something
like that all very hypothetical
well magnetic monopoles could be
produced
in the early universe and some of them
would still survive to today
and you might say okay well that's
probably true but they're probably rare
and hard to find
no in fact what you prove very pretty
quickly
is that uh the universe should be almost
all monopoles in ordinary grand unified
theories the
energy density of monopoles should be
orders of magnitude higher than the
energy density we observe in the
universe
today so there has to be something going
wrong with that
now there's an obvious solution to this
problem namely grand unified theories
are not correct
and grand unified theories remember made
the prediction that protons should decay
they should not live forever and people
looked for proton decay and didn't find
it
so very plausibly that's the actual
correct solution to this
problem so this is not a problem with
cosmology this the monopole problem is a
problem
that is at the intersection of cosmology
and a particular set of ideas for
fundamental particle physics namely
grand unified theories
that's what alan guth was working on as
a postdoc at stanford
when he was thinking about this he was
thinking about gage theories and
magnetic monopoles and he was a
latecomer to cosmology
so this is actually what motivated him
and then he went to a talk
i think it was by peebles but uh or
maybe by bob dickey yeah by bob dickey
so
bob dickey and jim peebles two very
famous cosmologists both of whom were at
princeton
and they collaborated on you know uh a
paper about
conundrums and puzzles in cosmology and
so they point out these other two
problems
one is called the flatness problem
and uh guth actually sat in the audience
for a lecture that dickie gave at
cornell where guth was also a postdoc
prior to stanford and he heard about
this problem and that sort of
settled in the back of his mind it's a
good lesson that you can actually learn
things by going to
lectures there you go so what is the
flatness problem
think about the friedman equation h
squared equals 8 pi g over 3
rho minus k over a squared okay
and i said you know if you have if rho
is constant
then the k over a squared term dilutes
away and becomes unimportant
but for ordinary matter and radiation so
you know think about what people were
thinking of in 1977 all right so they
weren't thinking about scalar fields
filling the universe they were not
thinking about the cosmological constant
they were thinking about particles and
photons matter and radiation so
for matter so we can rewrite this as 8
pi
g over 3. rho
matter has some value when a equals one
and then it goes like a to the minus
three
okay so i'm writing the energy entity in
matter which is
dependent on the scale factor as a
constant
times a to the minus three because the
number of particles just dilutes away as
the scale factor gets bigger
and the volume goes as a cubed radiation
we talked about
rho radiation starts at some fiducial
value and then goes as a to the minus
4 because the energy density and
radiation
is the number density goes down as a
cubed and then the energy per particle
goes down as as a because the wavelength
gets stretched
so then minus k a to the minus two
okay so this is what you would have been
thinking of as a cosmologist in the mid
70s you would think there's matter
there's radiation there could be
curvature we don't know
and so there's no term in here that is
constant and so
if you plot these puppies as a function
of the scale factor
rho i for matter radiation and call this
call this term row curvature
rho sub k it's not an energy density but
it enters the friedman equation in a way
very similarly to an energy density
what you find is of course there's a to
the minus three a to the minus four
a to the minus two so a to the minus
four goes down very quickly
that's radiation matter goes down
somewhat more slowly
and curvature goes down the
least slow at all so it's the opposite
story the story that we told for
inflation was if you have a constant
energy density curvature gets diluted
away
if you don't have a constant energy
density if you have curvature matter and
radiation
it's matter and radiation that get
diluted away and curvature always wins
okay so if you didn't know
if you didn't know what the initial
curvature of the universe was if you
thought for whatever reason
and maybe this for whatever reason
should be interrogated more carefully
but if you thought you know i don't know
there's some matter there's some
radiation there's some curvature
just start at some random values and let
them go what you would predict because
the scale factor has increased by many
orders of magnitude
what you would not maybe not predict but
expect naturally
is that the universe should be all
curvature it should be wildly curved the
curvature of space should be big
much bigger the matter density or the
radiation density in the friedman
equation
okay um it's not right even in the 70s
we knew the universe was not
really really curved euclidean geometry
works pretty well
on your tabletop right i mean the amount
of curvature we're talking here would be
noticeable in your everyday life
and that's not true so something went
wrong there so
the in the conventional cosmology um
the answer to this well the only way to
answer this is to say
you just start the universe with k
really really really really small so
that even if
it grows faster than matter and
radiation it still hasn't caught up to
them today or only just started
catching up to them today that's the
flatness problem the finest problem is
our universe looks pretty flat
you'd expect it to look really curved
why was the curvature so small
at early times and then there is the
uh the horizon problem
and the horizon problem comes from the
fact that you know you just look at the
universe with the cosmic microwave
background
in the 1970s they had they detected the
cosmic ray background in the 60s
they had not yet detected the
temperature fluctuations from place to
place so as far as they knew
the microwave background looked
perfectly smooth everyone knew it wasn't
perfectly smooth but the precision of
the experiments to the day
so it said that as far as they could
tell it looked smooth
and that's an issue because
here's another space-time diagram here's
time going up okay
and here we are right now here's us as
observers okay here's the past
let's say that this is the big bang
so this is well this is space and this
is t equals zero the big bang
let's say here is the cosmic microwave
background right remember 380 000 years
after the big bang
and this is a space-time diagram so
i should be consistent about the dashed
lines so we can draw
light cones backward in time
and what you notice here is that even
though space
can be infinitely big you're only
looking at a certain part of space
at any one time okay there's only a
certain part of the universe
that can possibly influence what happens
to you
so an event let's put this in colors an
event here
trying to draw a star and failing an
event that happens there i don't know
what kind of event happened before
recombination but maybe it would so the
causal influence can certainly
propagate upward in the universe and
affect you but
something that happens out here it just
can't get you even if it moves at the
speed of light
it is outside your light cone okay so
nothing that happens outside your light
cone
can possibly affect you and the thing
that is new
about cosmology is that there's a
beginning right in
flat space in minkowski space your light
cones traced into the past
just get bigger and bigger and bigger
you get more and more of the past of the
universe could
possibly influence you but here in
cosmology they are cut off
by the fact that the universe had a
beginning so if you look at
the points where your vision
your looking out at the universe and
looking at the cosmic microwave
background
so the points where your past light cone
intersects
the moment of recombination the moment
where the microwave background was
formed in some sense when the universe
became transparent
we can ask well what about the light
cones of those points
so look at the sky see the cosmic
microwave background
ask what it would be like to be living
at that point
in the microwave when the microwave
background was formed when the universe
was becoming transparent when the
electrons were recombining with protons
and helium nuclei
well they have a horizon also
well they have a past light cone okay so
you can call this
distance here the horizon
for this point right there whereas
this whole thing is the horizon for us
right there so the horizon in this case
is take your location in space time
trace your light cones back to the big
bang okay
that defines a region of space at or
very very very very close to the big
bang
call that your horizon and what you see
is if you call this point a
and point b right two different points
that you're looking at
in the cosmic microwave background
the horizons of a and b so this is
horizon sub
a this is horizon sub b
they're non-overlapping there's nothing
in literally nothing in the universe
that affects what happens at point a
and also affects what happens at point b
their past light cones are
non-overlapping again in minkowski space
in a non-expanding universe
you would just keep tracing those light
cones back and eventually they would
intersect each other
but here that's not true the big bang is
the beginning
it's the boundary to space and time okay
under this theory we haven't put
inflation yet that was the idea
the horizon problem is a problem
inflation's supposed to solve it
so the the specific problem is on the
one hand when you look at point a and b
these are two points in the cosmic
microwave background
they're the same temperature right they
are
2.7 degrees kelvin and that temperature
is set by the initial conditions of that
part of the universe its density its
expansion rate
number of photons number of electrons
all that stuff
that's true for both point a and point b
they have the same temperature
but in the conventional big bang model
they have non-overlapping
pasts nothing was uh causally
influencing both of them
now you could say that i have a theory
of
cosmology where you know stephen hawking
or god or the wave function of the
universe sets up initial conditions
at the universe at the beginning of the
universe
all over space instantaneously okay
because remember it could be infinitely
big
um well you know good for you that's
great good glad you have a theory like
that but we have no idea why
that should be the case or whether that
theory is true so the horizon problem
the point of the horizon problem is that
in the absence of
a specific predictive theory of what was
happening at the big bang
we have no reason no understanding of
why
the temperature in two very distant
regions of the cosmic microwave
background should be the same
how do they know to be the same even
though they have no causal
influence over each other and in fact
you can ask you how far apart
on the sky do you have to look to get
two points which are causally
disconnected in this way and the answer
about one degree
on the sky so you can go 360 times
around and get causally non-overlapping
regions of the cosmic microwave sky
that's the horizon problem okay and so
inflation solves all of these and i'm
not going to go
into detail well sorry inflation says it
solves all of these um
we kind of already know how it solves
the flatness problem because
it dilutes away the curvature right if
you start with a constant energy density
that energy density remains constant
while the curvature goes away
k over a squared degree decreases while
the energy density remains constant
and then at the end of inflation what
happens we're supposed to imagine is
there's sort of a drop off here at the
end of inflation
and at that point all the energy density
in the inflaton
converts into ordinary matter and
radiation it does not convert into
curvature
the inflaton is a field made of stuff
and that stuff decays into other stuff
that we know and love okay
so you create big matter and radiation
densities you do not create big
curvature and that explains why the
universe is flat
for the horizon problem roughly speaking
what inflation does is say well actually
the universe had been expanding a lot
longer than that
and i say roughly speaking because it's
not
in time that it had been uh spending a
lot longer than that but
it is expanded by a lot more than that
so these light cones that you were
tracing backward are
you know deserve to be traced backward a
lot more and in fact
they do have an overlapping past so
i hope no professional cosmologists are
listening here because i'm going to air
the dirty laundry
of cosmology both the horizon
problem and the flatness problem are
entirely bs all right i know that
everyone loves them and i
used to think they were great great in
the sense that they are good motivations
for inflation
if you read my general relativity book
there they are presented with all the
earnest
sincerity that a good cosmologist can
muster but they're entirely bogus
there are problems and there are
problems that inflation addresses
they're just not these problems
okay and the reason why very very
briefly is
the flatness problem is is entirely
bogus because
look you said you started with this
vague statement about
you know maybe the matter density the
radiation density the curvature maybe
they're all roughly equal to each other
and then what you need is that in fact
the curvature is much much much smaller
in order to be consistent with the data
today and then the implicit
step is how likely is that seems very
very unlikely that the curvature of the
universe would be very very small
right the thing is we have a measure
we talked about probability and measures
a little bit there is a measure defined
by general relativity
on the space of initial conditions and
in fact in that measure
which maybe you don't want to use but
it's literally the only one that is
predicted by the theory in that measure
the universe is overwhelmingly likely to
be flat
it is overwhelmingly likely to have an
infinitesimally tiny curvature
in other words if you pick a universe
randomly out of a box
probably that was not how our universe
was made but if you imagine doing
something like that
you would not imagine getting equal
amounts of matter radiation in curvature
you would imagine getting much more
matter radiation than curvature so
the flatness problem isn't a problem at
all it's just the most natural thing in
the world for the universe to be flat
the horizon problem is a little bit
trickier because in the horizon problem
also
has has a step in it that is a bit of a
cheat okay
the horizon problem says look there are
these two points uh
they're causally disconnected from each
other there is no
reason uh that there's no thing that
ever happened in history
the universe that set them to
synchronize in some way
so why should they be at the same
temperature
and then if you have inflation then they
do have
an overlapping causal past so they can
be
set to the same temperature right you
saw what happened there i didn't say
they are set to the same temperature i
just said they can be
and the point is that again i'm not
saying that inflation doesn't solve
problems i'm just saying this isn't the
way to say what the problems are
if you didn't have inflation if you just
for some reason
let the universe expand very very slowly
for a long time
you could also expand these light cones
so they would
overlap in the past but you wouldn't
expect these different parts of the
universe to equilibrate
the universe should become lumpier we
talked about this when we're talking
about entropy
right the universe should grow under
gravitational instability
its differences in matter density from
place to place
so we have an intuition from like an
ordinary box of gas where if you start a
box of gas
with cold on one side hot on one side
they will even out
right but that's not what happens in
cosmology they don't even out
because the gravity is important so they
become even more lumpier
so there's a sleight of hand being
pulled here in the horizon problem
of course inflation is not like a box of
gas
either so once you start inflation
then there is a reason why the two
different regions of the universe become
similar to each other and the reason why
that cosmic micro background is
homogeneous
so inflation does what it purports to do
it makes the universe spatially flat
homogeneous approximately the same
everywhere it predicts the kind of
universe we actually live in
but this motivational pep talk about the
horizon and flatness problem much less
the monopole problem
is a little bit off base
the just to drive that home a little bit
think about entropy
okay we said that
in the entropy video we said that there
is this issue of the past hypothesis
okay why is the entropy of the early
universe
so small so if you think about
our universe today so here's today
and think about some earlier time let's
think about um
i don't know near the think about near
the cmp near the recombination
okay the universe was smaller but the
reason why that's a perfectly good
place to think about is because there
were no black holes or anything like
that i mean the universe was pretty much
smooth near the cmb the the variations
in density from place to place were one
part in a hundred thousand ten to the
minus five
very very tiny so this is a co-moving
volume
okay this is a region of space that has
moved that is its definition of its
boundaries is moving along with
the matter in the universe and the
entropy
at this time cmb this means not the
entropy of the cmb but the entropy
of our observable co-moving patch of
universe
at the time the cmb was formed is about
10 to the 88th
we know that because it's a box of gas
it really is just a bunch of particles
and we know from the 1800s formulas for
calculating the entropy of bunches of
particles
today the entropy of the universe is
much higher why
because gravitational instability has
had time to work it's
made black holes uh i said that the
black hole the center of our galaxy all
by itself
has an entropy of something like 10 to
the 90th bigger than the whole universe
at the cmb time so the entropy has gone
up
um i forget actually what the number is
today but
it's something like 10 to the 100 and
well it's over 10 to the 100 let's let's
put it that way it's gone up by a lot
okay
10 to 103 maybe i'm forgetting the
number i used to know this number off
the top of my head but anyway
it's gone up that's what matters and the
point is if you trace
this let's say this is what we know and
then you trace backwards
okay into what we don't know well if you
just did the conventional big bang
right so s ordinary big bang
obb ordinary big bang it's still about
10 to the 88th
right and it's still just a box of gas
with a bunch of particles in it maybe
slightly fewer particles maybe it's 10
to 87 or something like that
in fact actually it is smaller than that
maybe 10 to 86
there are fewer particles is that right
yeah something like that entropy's only
going to go up
but um okay entropy went up and
there's still a long way for it to go
you know the entropy that you could get
if you took all the matter in our
universe and put in a black hole as
roger penrose has emphasized is over 10
to 120.
so 10 120 is much bigger than 10 to the
103
but 10 to 103 is much bigger than 10 to
the 86 so
there's a huge problem why was the
entropy of the early universe so
small and inflation is supposed to be a
theory
that tells you that makes the initial
conditions of the universe
natural but inflation says well the
reason why
the entropy of the universe was small
then is because it started
with a little inflationary patch with an
entropy of order 10
or something like that you know 1 or 10
to the 10 to the 3 or something like
that it's an incredibly tiny number
that's what you need to have this little
remember we talked about what happens
when you start inflation
you have a scalar field and it has
energy density which is its time
derivative
and its potential you notice we did not
have
a spatial derivative
d phi dx
okay where x is little vector there was
no
energy from the variations in the field
from place to place in space
that was an assumption that there wasn't
any why
well because if there were inflation
wouldn't start that energy density would
dilute away
very very quickly and you not have this
constant push to the expansion of the
universe
so you assume that there isn't that much
as we say gradient energy at early times
that assumption i'm skipping some steps
but that assumption is equivalent
to saying that the entropy of the early
universe was super duper
small so inflation explains the low
entropy of the early universe by saying
that there was an even lower entropy at
earlier times
which is obviously cheating that is not
okay right
um this is why i am personally
ambivalent about
inflation on the one hand it's good it
solves a lot it explains
let's put it this way forget about words
like solves and explains
it predicts that the universe should
look like
the universe we see that's why inflation
is good that's one reason the other
reason is
to start inflation it needs to be very
this is a very small
amount of space you know the in ordinary
big bang
you know the early universe that
corresponds to our observable universe
today was i forget but it's you know
millimeters or micrometers something
like that which is a small
size compared to the universe today but
enormously big
compared to particle physics scales
whereas in inflation
the universe could start as small as the
planck scale and then
expand so inflation provides
in principle a bridge from a true theory
of quantum gravity that explains
what the universe was doing when it's at
the planck scale to the observable
universe with the microwave background
and all that stuff
and via that bridge it predicts the
universe should look like the universe
we see
that's why i think it's an attractive
theory i just don't think it actually
solves any of the puzzles that it was
purported to solve either
because it doesn't or because those
puzzles are
not really puzzles right the real puzzle
is the entropy puzzle and it totally
boots that one it totally just assumes
that the
entropy of the universe was small what
can i say
all right that's my little rant about
inflation for today
let's see we have some other questions
those are those are the major ones i
want to get to but we have some other
fun ones uh one was why does the why
does general relativity
predict that the universe is either
expanding or contracting remember that's
what
got einstein hot and bothered when he
realized oh no my theory is incompatible
with the data
so remember the friedman equation i'm
going to write it again so i don't have
to keep referring back
8 pi g over 3 rho minus k over a squared
so we're putting the curvature in
um well look
the prediction that the universe is
either expanding or contracting
is just a prediction that h is not equal
to zero right
if you don't have the curvature term so
let's say that you just erase this
right if there's no curvature if you're
in a flat universe
then clearly the universe has to be
expanding or contracting
h is a non-zero number so h
because it's h squared h could be
positive or negative
right so he could either be expanding or
contracting but it's definitely not zero
if you don't have the cosmological
constant because he didn't invent it yet
in 1917.
so you could put back in the curvature
term
right and then you could say okay why
don't i balance it why don't i say that
k is greater than zero
that's squared sorry k is greater than
zero um
rho is some number and they exactly
cancel maybe that's what it is
but then you have to say okay that's
perfectly okay but then you have to look
at the next
there's another equation that we weren't
looking at before okay the point is
h is one over oops
let's write it as a dot over a so that
depends on the first derivative
of a but there is another equation for
the second derivative of
a and what you find if you plug in
i'm not showing you what that equation
is it's a mess but
if you set the universe to be exactly h
equals zero
by balancing rho and k the second
derivative
of the scale factor with time is not
zero so if you
truly have a universe that is not
expanding so if you think
that what you're getting is as a
function of time here's the scale factor
if you think you're getting this
okay um that's not compatible because
that would be
a solution where the scale factor has 0
first derivative
0 second derivative zero third
derivative it's literally not changing
instead what einstein's equation by the
friedman equation predicts
is you are at the peak of a universe
that is expanding and then contracting
again
okay so that's what you would actually
live in so there's no universe
in general relativity with the with the
ingredients of curvature matter and
radiation
no cosmological constant that could just
be constant and stay constant that's not
an allowed
solution um so that's why einstein had
to invent the cosmological constant once
he gets
uh some once he gets a universe where
there is a cosmological constant then
you can balance everything out again i'm
not going to go to the details but that
becomes possible but that's where the
prediction comes from
which is related to the question of you
know is there
a relationship between the fate of the
universe and the geometry of the
universe
there is but kind of it becomes messy
and this is probably less important for
me to explain now than it would have
been
20 years ago but when i was your age we
were taught that there was an ironclad
relationship
between the geometry of space positively
curved flat or negatively curved
and the future of the universe
because if you have h squared equals 8
pi g over 3 it's getting sloppy here
over 3
minus k over a squared if that's your
equation oops
rho sorry and there's no cosmological
constant
lambda equals zero then you can actually
show it's pretty easy to show
that as time goes on and the scale
factor goes on
there's two possibilities um well let's
put it this way
there is here's what would happen if the
universe let's just say that rho is
matter
okay row matter is proportional to a to
the minus three
you can put in radiation but it doesn't
really matter as long as we don't put in
the cosmological constant
so here is the universe where k equals
zero
then a is proportional to t to the two
thirds
this is my attempt to draw t to the two
thirds
if k is a negative number then the
universe will expand forever
also so t to the two thirds expands
forever
k is less than zero
the universe also expands forever and
whenever k
is greater than 0 look at what happens
if k is greater than 0
the matter dilutes away as the universe
expands
the curvature dilutes away also but more
slowly right
so if the curvature is small initially
the matter is what is matter
what matters as it were in the universe
um that's good but eventually it will
catch up
so eventually this k over a squared term
which is negative for k
equals greater greater than zero this k
over a squared term will exactly balance
the
matter term eventually if you wait long
enough so
positively curved universes look like
this
k greater than zero and so there is a
relationship
positively curved universes are finite
in time
negatively curved universes can last
forever okay
um sadly so that was a very nice thing
because when people
thought they were measuring the spatial
geometry of the universe they
said we're measuring the future of the
universe we're going to tell you whether
it expands forever or not
um once they realized in 1980 1998 that
the cosmos constant was greater than
zero
they had to rewrite all those statements
because i mean they should have known
all along and the best ones did know all
along but the cosmological constant
changes this
set of predictions then if you a better
way to plot it let me see if i can
actually do this correctly
[Music]
the parameter space which we might want
to draw is
well i need to tell you what omega is
don't i well okay i will here is omega
matter
here is omega lambda so omega
is the density parameter of the universe
and we're imagining once again a
universe that is just matter and
cosmological constant now no radiation
doesn't change anything
qualitatively omega i is
8 pi g
over 3 rho over h squared
so we take the friedman equation and we
divide both sides
by h squared okay so we get something
that is normalized in some nice way
and so h so in other words
this with this definition
we get 1 equals omega
minus k over a squared h squared
okay so you see that instantly you can
get
k equals a squared
h squared times uh let me get it right
omega minus 1. so there's instantly
a relationship between the density
density curvature parameter density
parameter
density parameter
and the curvature namely if omega is
greater than one then k is a positive
number
if omega is less than one then k is an
is a negative number
so omega even though it's a measure of
density if you believe the friedman
equation
instantly tells you the curvature of
space that's why it's called
that's why it's a useful way of
parameterizing the
density and so if you have matter and
the cosmological constant what we what
we care about what you thought you cared
about is
is omega total greater than one right
that tells you the spatial curvature
so here's the line
omega total
equals omega matter plus omega lambda
equals one right so here
for omega greater than one k is greater
than zero
this way k is less than zero
on the line k equals zero
so the way to think about this is the
the new thing that enters with the
cosmological constant is
go back to the k greater than zero case
with no cosmological constant
okay if you think about these two terms
that are on the right hand side of the
friedman equation what's going on
the matter is always expanding the
universe
right i mean the way to think about this
in terms of einstein's equation is
energy density sources the curvature of
space-time and the expansion of
space-time the expansion of space
is one version of the curvature of
space-time one way in which
space-time can be curved the spatial
curvature is another way it sort of
divides up that way in cosmology
so rho is positive therefore h squared
kind of wants to be positive right
but if k is greater than zero k over a
squared
goes away more slowly than k over then
something over a cubed like the matter
density does
so as the universe expands this term
will always start
to dominate and this term wants to
cancel off
the push that the energy density of the
universe is getting from that the
expansion rate of the universe is
getting from matter so eventually these
two terms will be of the same
size and they will say h equals zero and
that traces out this
path that's the zero point and then it
will recollapse
okay so the basic mechanism is that k
over a squared the curvature
always goes away more slowly than the
matter
but when you have a cosmological
constant the cosmological constant if
it's positive
wants to make the universe expand
positive energy density and i know this
is a little bit
counterintuitive positive
matter let me let's put it this way
matter like galaxies dark matter
slows the expansion of the universe down
but at the same time
make sure the universe is still
expanding right so
that's why we talk about the
deceleration of the universe
if we didn't know about the cosmological
constant the universe would expand but
ever more slowly and you see that
in the a goes as t to the two cubed
two-thirds uh curve so there's these two
effects going on
okay rho slows down the expansion the
universe because galaxies pull on each
other
but also it can't be zero if it's just
matter because h squared is proportional
to rho
as long as there is energy density and
we don't have a curvature or a negative
energy density the universe has to
expand
a negative cosmological constant okay
can make the universe recollapse a
positive cosmological constant though
wants to push it so matter goes away
faster than the curvature so if matter
is positive
and curvature is negative they can
cancel but if you have a positive
cosmological constant
that goes away even more slowly than
matter than curvature does because it
doesn't go away at all
positive cause marshall constant will
always win at the end of the day
and so in this little diagram here what
you get is
let's get a different color for k less
than zero i should i should have said
this more explicitly before it's easy to
know what happens when k is less than
zero
without the cosmological constant the
universe wants to expand forever
if there's a negative cosmological
constant that will always eventually win
because it doesn't dilute away so the
inverse expands and expands
gets rid of all the matter all the
curvature and all you have is a negative
cosmological constant which forces the
universe to re-collapse
so we can draw the dividing line like
this
so this is uh i can just draw
keep drawing it this way so these are
universes that
expand forever
and these are universes that re-collapse
okay so for on this line where omega
lambda equals zero then it's just is
omega matter
greater than or equal to one um when
omega lambda is not zero when there's
any cosmological constant
a negative cosmological constant always
makes the universe re-collapse
what about when omega matter is greater
than
one that means that without the cosmos
constant the universe would be
positively curved and would recollapse
okay well if it's just right there's a
little window in there the universe gets
big big enough that the you might think
it's going to re-collapse
but the cosmological constant becomes
important so if there's a positive
cosmological constant
a positive cosmological constant wants
the universe to expand
forever the only way to stop that from
happening
is if the matter is big enough that it
causes the universe to recollapse
before the cosmological constant can
take over
so in this plot you see there's a region
that kind of looks like this
okay so in this little wedge down there
even though there's a positive
cosmological constant
you don't have enough time for it to
matter the universe recollapses so this
is still the re-collapsing
and this is still the expand forever so
but notice that
this to the top side of the
diagonal line let's let's make the
diagonal line different colors so it
kind of stands out
here's the diagonal line this is the
spatial curvature line right
so these are negatively curved universes
below
the line and some of them re-collapse
but they will expand forever if they
have a positive cosmological constant
sorry
that's obvious when curvature is
negative they want to expand forever
they will still do that if the cosmos
constant is positive but if the hospital
constant is negative
even a negatively curved universe will
recollapse
whereas if the curvature is positive it
depends on the details of exactly the
relative amount of
cosmological constant to matter so the
point is the very long way away once
again of saying that
things become complicated once you allow
there to be both matter and cosmos
constant the simple relationship between
the fate of the universe and its
geometry its spatial geometry
is no longer there okay um
yes i want to talk about energy
conservation because people did mention
this and this is a thing
uh i mentioned it but let me mention say
one more thing about it
entropy i always think about entropy
energy
conservation
remember i said that if you have a box
of universe here's space but i'm
sort of making it look three-dimensional
now it's going to expand as before
i'm going to move this whole thing down
to give me more room
so it expands you have more space
so if the universe has nothing in it but
matter particles slowly moving particles
then in that expanding region the energy
density goes the number of particles
that remains constant the energy remains
constant
but so rho let me put it this way
um let's define
the energy in the box let me move this
box a little bit here
there's something i can define which
maybe might not be a good thing to
define if you're a professional
cosmologist but it gets
intuitively to what's going on here i
will define the energy inside the box
as the integral over the volume of the
box
of rho the energy density right so i
just add up inside the box the energy
density
and then as the universe expands uh
for matter
ebox equals constant
for radiation
the number of radiation particles
remains the same but the energy per
particle goes down
so ebox
decreases
and for vacuum energy
the energy per cubic centimeter remains
the same the total number of cubic
centimeters goes up
so e-box increases
and the question is um
is there some way that we can describe
this
as the energy going into the
gravitational field
right can we can we somehow rescue
conservation of energy by saying that
really what we're doing here is talking
about the energy matter and radiation
uh and vacuum but there's also the
energy of the gravitational field
and the answer there is you know not
really honestly
like i wish there were but it's not
quite like
that if you follow the structure of the
equations of general relativity
there's no natural way to associate
uh with anything that appears in those
equations the energy of a box including
the gravitational field and everything
else so that it remains constant
but i think that's okay like i don't
think it should bother you people tried
and you know in
other circumstances it kind of works
right you can sort of fudge your way
into it
but i think there's a different way of
thinking about it the way of thinking
about it is
there's still an equation right the
equation used to be
the equation of energy conservation
in non-expanding universes just says
d e d t equals zero
right where it you know it doesn't
change over time the energy of a closed
system
so this is before gr came along but now
we have an expanding universe
and it's not that the equation just
disappears it goes to d
e dt is some function of
the kinds of matter we have
and what space-time is doing
how the universe is expanding so general
relativity predicts a very specific
equation for how these things change and
you you know that
right as the universe expands the vacuum
energy is proportional to the volume
the radiation density goes down as the
scale factor goes up it's exactly like
that it's not like
all craziness is broken loose there's
something very very definite
that happens so this is my particular
way of doing it you know the
reason why this is worth saying even
though it's kind of a fuzzy conclusion
because different cosmologists like to
use different words for this
um is that it's a lesson
that different cosmologists like to use
different words for this the words
aren't what matter
right all the cosmologists who will
slightly disagree
about is energy conserved or not in
expanding universe
they all agree on the equations they
have zero disagreement about physically
what is happening
the only disagreement is as to what is
most convenient to
attach to equations and words which was
the most
convenient way to attach words to the
equations okay that is something that
people can disagree about and
the lesson that i'm trying to get across
is that's fine like who cares about that
you know i don't even say that people
who disagree about this particular
vocabulary are wrong
i just say they're just using different
vocabulary words to express
what is going on okay so that's a good
lesson to end on here i think that uh
you know there's many more things to say
there are a lot of good questions a lot
of good things to talk about
oh wait yeah no there's one one thing i
just got to talk about sorry
you were hopeful that we're going to end
but there's one more thing to talk about
uh is brooklyn expanding
this of course is uh
a illusion
reference to a scene in annie hall the
woody hall
woody allen movie where young uh woody
allen is at the
therapist's office and he's uh full of
anxiety because the universe is
expanding and his mother tells you what
do you care the universe is expanding
brooklyn is not expanding
but people wonder about that they say
wait a minute um
the universe is expanding but pretty
slowly right you know the universe the
expansion the universe is not a speed
it's not a velocity
any one galaxy has a velocity but
hubble's constant is velocity equals
distance times
the hubble constant so for different
distances
galaxies move at different velocities
the best way to think about the hubble
constant is as a rate
you can think about you know the hubble
constant h in the real world there's a
controversy over what the value of h
is today h naught but roughly speaking
it's approximately 70 in units of
kilometers per second
per megaparsec now these are silly units
remember when we talked about units
uh earlier what this means is of course
we have velocity
equals hubble constant times distance so
this is measured in kilometers per
second
distance is measured in megaparsecs
so the hubble constant converts from
distance to velocity and that's why it's
in these weird units
but these units are distance divided by
time divided by distance
so this has units of one over time
it does not have units of velocity
that's crucially important
so these are convenient units to use but
the actual physical thing going on is
one over time because the hubble
constant is basically saying
how much time does it take for the
universe to double in size
okay so we talk about the hubble time
t h which is just
1 over the hubble constant i am setting
all
c equal one things like that but i think
in this case c the speed of light
doesn't even appear
and this is about you know 10 billion
years right 10 to the 10 years
roughly speaking so what this is saying
is it takes almost 10 billion years for
the universe to double in size
and so in one year
or 10 years the universe doesn't expand
by very much
so you might very well ask
[Music]
is it possible that brooklyn is
expanding or at least the solar system
brooklyn is held together by the
structural forces of the earth right and
you know the ground and
the buildings and so forth but less
poetically
is the solar system expanding because
planets are not bound
by material objects to the sun right is
the earth
slowly moving away from the sun because
of the expansion of the universe and we
just haven't noticed
because the expansion of the universe is
so small so the answer is
no that's the answer
the answer is not it's expanding very
slowly it's not expanding
at all or rather it may be doing all
sorts of weird things you know the solar
system is buffeted
by the gravitational fields of other
stars and gravitational waves passing
through so there's always
slight deviations in the distances
between the planets and the sun
but it is not overall either expanding
or contracting
at all okay
it is hard for me to explain that i've
two ways of explaining it neither one of
which
have historically been very effective
but i'll give them both of you the first
one is just in words
um you can think of
here not just in words i'll draw a
picture so here's time once again
space okay and this is the expansion of
the universe but rather than drawing
the parallelogram to be all space let me
draw some
particles okay and as the universe
expands the particles move further apart
from each other
this is what it means to be an expanding
universe
right
not the prettiest diagram ever but there
you go and
you can think of this as sort of just
inertial motion given some initial
conditions okay
uh it is almost kind of halfway
analogous to take a baseball and throw
it into the sky
throw it very very fast you know that if
you throw an object
away from the earth uh for realistic
amounts of velocity that you can give
the baseball it will come back after a
while go up and then come down
but if there is a escape velocity where
if you throw it fast enough
the thing will just take off into outer
space and never come back
okay so you can think of the expansion
of the universe as kind of like that
this picture that i drew here
corresponds to a perfectly uniform
initial condition which we think is is
true but
um but sorry it's almost true but it's
not
perfect right there are deviations there
are slightly over dense and under dense
regions
so if you have some set of particles
more nearby
that are in over dense region they will
pull together and they will sort of
initially be expanding apart but then
they will start collapsing together
and we call this the formation of a
galaxy or something like that right
a galaxy or a star or whatever and so
the first explanation
is to why brooklyn is not expanding or
the solar system's not expanding is that
these bound structures
have departed is to part of the right
word um
yeah okay they well the part is not the
right word
they have left
the decoupled from the expansion of the
universe
what is affecting their dynamics
is their local interactions not the
expansion of the universe
and people don't like that they say well
look if i have you know
if they go back to the analogy right
like the rubber sheet is being pulled
apart or the balloon is being blown up
if you
if you take a a small balloon and you
put dots on it with a magic marker
and then you blow it up it's not only
that the dots get further apart the dots
get bigger
right and so they say like maybe there
is a tiny effect or if the rubber sheet
if i have you know if i draw pictures on
the rubber sheet and i pull it apart
then
everything gets bigger that's just not a
good analogy the analogy has broken down
in that case uh it's much better if you
think of the rubber sheet and you put
pennies
on the rubber sheet or coins on the
rubber sheet you pull them apart right
the coins get further apart as you pull
the rubber sheet but they don't get
bigger they might have infinitesimally
incredibly tiny
force exerted on them by the sheet below
them
but then there's a restoring force from
the tension inside the coin so they
don't get bigger
at all um the raisins in the raisin
bread if you put them
in uh the oven another famous analogy
for the expanding universe is raisin
bread you put in the oven let it expand
the raisins don't expand along with the
bread because they're held together by
the forces inside the raisin
it's even more true here for the
universe because
there's just as many things pulling it
together or more things pulling it
together than
pulling it apart so that's one
explanation the other explanation is
i can give you an exact solution to
einstein's equation that
is not exactly the real world but
might be that resembles the real world
in an evocative way
so let me draw not space time but just
space
so here is space okay
and i imagine that i fill space with
stuff dense matter right
so i do this correctly it will be
exactly the same
shade of gray everywhere representing
the fact that the matter
is perfectly smooth
there we go okay and so
in this case this represents a universe
where
it's exactly homogeneous everywhere
exactly uniform and it would expand and
continue to be exactly uniform so that
is
a solution to einstein's equations for
cosmology but now
let me take this and duplicate it
let me give you another solution
einstein's equation
i can take a circular region
let me take it this way i can take a
circular region in this universe
and i don't eliminate all the matter in
it but i take all the matter that was
in that region and i move it to the
center okay so i put it all
right in the middle
and i can do that at various points so i
can do that over here and it doesn't
even matter the size i can do a bigger
region
oops i can't make it lumpy it needs to
be perfectly spherical that's the rule
of the game
it's perfectly spherical then all the
matter went there so
you're imagining that the matter
collapsed to that central point okay
and i don't disturb
the particles that are still left in
between but i can do this i can make
this hole
called a vacuole and i can make a hole
in the universe
and contract all the matter to the
center
and as the universe expands it turns out
this as long as the amount of matter
that i put at the center of that region
is the same that was in there before i
evacuated it
this is still an exact solution to
einstein's equation so
in other words if i'm living here at
some point
in the uniform distribution of matter i
don't notice
that i've changed from this picture to
that picture the dynamics near me oops
is exactly the same what even happened
there okay
so what that means is that the size of
the region expands along with the
universe
and the life within
this region so if we live here a little
galaxy
the metric of space-time in that region
has zero expansion it is the short
shield metric
locally it is the metric of a single
blob of matter
with a spherically symmetric vacuum
around it
there is exactly zero
uh influence of the fact that it's
surrounded by an expanding universe
so this is not a completely realistic
version of the universe we live in but
it is a an analogy
a close relative of it to drive home the
fact that we can have an exact solution
einstein's equation
in which the universe as a whole is
expanding and in local regions where
things have become over dense and
collapsed
there is precisely zero expansion it's
not that there's just a little bit and
we can solve the equations exactly and
we can show that
so the analogies that we use for the
expansion of the universe are helpful in
some ways and not helpful in other ways
and this is a way
in which uh they're the the balloon and
the raisin bread and all these things
are slightly less than perfect
brooklyn's not expanding the solar
system's not expanding nothing like that
the universe
is expanding though all right and this
is you know like i said there are many
more questions that i could have
answered
uh the cosmology it's a big field
there's a lot going on
i encourage you to you know hit up the
internet and uh look for more
information because you'll never stop
learning more about how cool the
universe is